and the most ridiculous of all came from
elizabeth warren
who said that trump is not just
threatening one specific group in her
case i suppose the cherokee
but that president trump is threatening
all life on earth
we are reaching a moment on our planet
in which the crisis that is upon us
may no longer be one that we will be
able to successfully fight back against
the climate crisis is here and no
it is not the science around this is not
controversial
the science is clear in fact you know
what scares me to death
is every time we get more data and
reanalyze the data what we discover is
the problems even worse than we thought
we have even less time than we thought
and so what has donald trump done for
four years
he not only hasn't made things better he
has actively
made them worse donald trump threatens
the existence of human life of
all life on this planet can somebody get
senator warren a fainting couch please
she is becoming
positively hysterical she i love this
idea that the democrats always do this
because they're always fear-mongering
they're doing it on the virus as
president trump said to the press right
at the very top of the show today
and they're doing it on the environment
they're doing it they've been doing it
for decades and decades they used to do
it on population the population
bomb were all going to be starving by
the 1980s what happened
the world population doubled and people
have never been richer fatter
they they do it where they did it with
global cooling in the 1970s and we're
all heading for an ice age and then now
they're doing with global warming and
who knows they're going to do it with
global
moderation pretty so who knows she goes
listen listen we we told you that
the world was going to end in 12 years
well now it's actually ah it's going to
be sooner even
is it sooner ten years is that well is
that enough to get you all
terrified i've had nine years how about
it's gonna end in 95 minutes if you
don't vote for us right now please
please vote for us help us the world is
gonna end
i don't think so aoc told what is it two
years ago she told us it was going to
end in 12 years keep
track of that clock by the way because
now we're down to 10 or even less than
10.
actually a couple years ago prince
charles one of the kookier members of
the british royal family
told us the world was going to end in 18
months which by my
by my clock means that the world has
ended
it's over we've it's ended and i guess
are we in heaven now are we in hell
uh-oh well looking around the political
scene
doesn't feel like heaven obviously these
things are preposterous the world
is not i mean no one knows the time or
the hour but at least the sun monster is
probably not going to end the world
within
elizabeth warren's timetable they're
ginning up this
hysteria on the racial issue like john
leguizamo and then on the
global planetary issue like elizabeth
warren
because they're losing power i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts